what do you do when you've made hundreds
of videos and the one that does really
spectacularly well
does well because people thought that it
was gonna be giraffe sex what do you do
[Music]
I'll tell you what you do John you write
a song about it
I made a video about ten months ago I
thought that I would show you something
beautiful I showed a picture with an
intimate nature but I didn't realize
till a hundred thousand views later and
that I don't know where we'd be where
would the vlogbrothers be without people
who love giraffes who love giraffes Oh
love is a beautiful thing
o tortoises and elephants and rhinos and
onion rings and cats and dogs in mice
and whales and even people too you
didn't think that I was gonna show porn
did you but where would we be where
would you to be without people who love
giraffes loved your ass the end love can
be pretty screwed
like that on the sexual necrophiliac
duck and this dachshund that's getting
it on with a cat and bunnies doing it
with chickens well I don't think that
I'm down with that but where would we be
where would America be without people
love giraffes who love giraffes and who
knows there may even be those who love
ducks who love Bucks love those oh where
would we be where would we be without
people love giraffes who love giraffes
ooh where would we be where would we be
without fuel who loved your ass
[Music]
love giraffes never in my life have I
done so many Google searches that were
so frightening type in search term click
close eyes peek through closed eyes
closed eyes backpack backpack the Google
safe search is pretty good but sometimes
things that technically aren't even
dirty are not things that you want to
see Donna know exactly what you're
talking about whatever you get a haircut
they're like oh does only take your Gus
and you're like no no I want to see what
you're doing fantastic saying my ass I
hope that I haven't disturbed or scarred
anyone if you were not disturbed or
scarred hopefully maybe you even enjoyed
John excited about reading
slaughterhouse-five again and everyone
post your blurbs at nerdfighters common
we'll have a vote next week also whether
nerdfighters comm news there's a forum
now so go forming John and I will be on
there John I'll see you tomorrow
no I won't